jack
am i gonna help with some pickling
please oh definitely no you love pickles
right love pickles um favorite pickle
what is it i like pickled onions we're
gonna do pickled celery mm-hmm it's a
nice little snack and great for plum
ones great for salads first thing i'm
going to pick the celery for me so you
see where the next one's going to be
it's in there yeah okay i'll figure out
well i'm hungry today is this all we're
having for dinner jack come on i
wouldn't do that too you know that
there's more coming now because we're
picking it
we want to sort of make it
look
a little bit more attractive so we go
around like that
okay on an angle
so when you pick all the food does it
does it preserve it it's exactly what it
does but also gives it a really nice
salty
soury flavor yeah okay now splash of
water and then with the sugar nice okay
so gotta bring that up to the bowl
and sort of create
almost like a little syrup yeah okay
little teaspoon of peppercorns in
mustard seeds in quite generous on the
mustard seeds that gives a bit of sort
of spice now those you must know
cloves excellent cloves
in
now touch of salt in there
okay
so from there white wine vinegar
now
in order for all that to actually
pickle you need to boil it
so by boiling it
okay it brings all the ingredients
together infuses all the spices
and
helps cook the celery have a little
taste
nice nice see i put some hairs on your
chest yes it was good look boom it's
working already now see
nice
vinegar
right celery's ready yeah okay let's
walk to the ball
now turn that off
now
from there
start placing the celery
into that jar so when you pick other
foods can you use that same recipe
exactly that
100
once it's pickled it doesn't really go
off mm-hmm okay now put them in there so
can we eat this straight away when it's
in here do you know what as soon as it's
cooled down
you can definitely eat that straight
away can't wait to dig into it at dinner
are they delicious yes we'll leave that
to cool down
our pickles are ready and cooling now to
marinate the chicken when you fried
chicken traditionally it's always gonna
be done with the dark meat the brown
meat so you've got that nice sort of uh
drum
here and this bit
that thigh cooking on the bone as well
keeps it even more moist so first things
first salt pepper please
from there famous buttermilk buttermilk
in it's brilliant for marinade in the
chicken if you can put this
buttermilk over your chicken
the night before the more it tenderizes
the chicken and starts to sort of really
relax the chicken and puts a really nice
sort of creamy soury flavor in there so
might stick that in the fridge for us
please
the buttermilk should have worked its
magic on the chicken all that's left is
to fry it
now we're gonna
roll the chicken out of the buttermilk
into the flour so that's why it gets
nice and crispy and blistery on the
outside
okay cool so what we've got to make sure
because the flour is the last coat yes
this is nicely seasoned yeah okay so
salt and pepper in there
nice
and this
is smoked paprika
so that gives it a little bit of sort of
uh
maintenance yeah yeah spice let's try a
little bit of heat and this one my
favorites what's that
cayenne pepper that's right again
slightly spicy but
the heat works brilliantly well
garlic powder traditionally are used a
lot in the steaks onion powder garlic
powder just run your fingers through
that please cool i'm gonna get the pan
on now
two centimetres
of oil this is a really good mix for
fish as well mm-hmm gujon's fighting
a nice spicy
texture
helps fish
so first thing
is we just shake off some of the
buttermilk lay that down yes okay really
important to get them covered completely
okay in the flour yeah okay
so i love fried chicken do you
now
lift that up there first one and you
place it in there away from you off you
go nice and gently
good and lay away good
if any stage you think the oil is
getting too hot yep just add a touch of
cold oil in there yeah or turn off the
gas
good
gently fry the chicken for 25 to 30
minutes or until cooked through
now very carefully turn them over please
yeah cool
can we have this every day
jack fried chicken every day no
definitely not it's a treat and it's
shallow fried so once every three weeks
yeah sounds great to me yeah
now
off with the gas
okay yeah paper ready okay onto the
paper
[Music]
i love
fried chicken i'm telling you i'm pretty
sure i love it look here's the best bit
delicious now fried chicken
or pickles if you pick up um dolce de
leche cakes we are ready bud
very nice that's good
delicious uncle mummy wow tilly phoenix
my pickled celery and buttermilk fried
chicken a soulful street food feast if
there ever was one
and joining the ramsay clan tonight is
tilly's schoolmate phoebe
now first of all we have some very very
exciting pickled celery baby um i'll
have a drum please here we go nice
ladies you can lift it up with your
fingers especially on the drums because
i can't do this
finger licking chicken that's right baby
how's the chicken
amazing i won't be able to like make
this at all yes you would yes you will
it's so easy to make you see yourself
it's very easy to make right
dad did say we could have it every night
in the week
what i said as a treat
it's chicken so it's healthy right you
always take you always tell me to eat my
chicken well chicken is healthy but not
fried every night okay
you